what do we have here yeah here i thought
we were special fellas this here's bag
man hang man whatever what the hell kind
of mission is this
[Music]
everyone here is the best there is who
the hell are they gonna get to teach us
captain pete maverick mitchell
let me be perfectly blunt
you are not my first choice you were
here at the request of admiral kazansky
aka iceman he seems to think that you
have something left to offer the navy
what that is i can't imagine
you all due respect sir i'm not a
teacher
i just want to manage expectations
what the hell
good morning aviators
this is your captain speaking
and we're off
here we go
in three
two
one
we're going into combat on a level no
living pilot's ever seen
not even him
you think up there you're dead believe
me
my dad believed in you
i'm not gonna make the same mistake
[Music]
someone's not coming back from this
those are your pilots
anything
you will never forgive yourself
no turning back now come on
[Music]
having any fun yet
[Music]
are you hungry for something good
[Music]
something juicy
[Music]
beefy
[Music]
hot burgers sexy burgers lin what it's
summer and sex sells baby
big things are coming for summertina
take off those bulky jeans to be more
aerodynamic oh you're doing it already
great big things like that heat rash you
get sometimes
bigger
stay low follow my lead
come come sleep
how about what
just the gasp is great thank you like
this
i think we got it that last one was good
okay
not what i was expecting
i'm the marketing department i took
gene's burger suit let out the crotch a
little bit and bam a burger with a
bikini on it oh yeah
i get it no questions from this guy
[Music]
is time to stop seeing
[Music]
it is time to stop speaking
[Music]
it is time
to listen
it is time to stop seeing
it is time to start speaking
it is time
to listen
listen
listen
listen
[Music]
[Music]
she too
i uh
you don't speak romaine
[Music]
you don't like
no it's lovely
there's this guy that lives across the
street and he's always looking over here
looking over here how
every time i look over there he's just
staring right at me
[Music]
hello darling
any reason in particular you're standing
in the dark
do you feel like coming in for a drink
yeah have you noticed anyone watching
you in your apartment no
this guy has been watching us since we
moved in
maybe he's staring at the woman who's
staring at him
[Music]
uh
[Music]
what's happening
they found a woman murdered in her
apartment they're saying the woman had
her head cut off
it's a man at the movie theater followed
me into the supermarket followed you
that's him
i need to know for myself that he's been
following me
sometimes i
just look at people
just tell me what you want me to want
you to believe me
i'm sure that you'd seen me
i heard screaming from in here okay just
open the door please
dreaming of the old pretty girl
looking back at me
[Applause]
but no one has really noticed before
[Music]
blue had a baby that's impossible
hey girl
you look just like your mother
[Music]
genetic power has now been unleashed
we made a terrible mistake
the doomsday clock might be about out of
time
if our world's gonna survive what
matters is what we do now
i could use your expertise
you coming or what
a baby raptor i made a promise we would
bring her home
you made a promise
to a dinosaur
yeah what
[Music]
everybody hold on to somebody
that can't be right
is that biggest carnivore the world has
ever seen
see not so bad
[Music]
buzz lightyear mission log stardate 3901
after a full year of being marooned our
first hyper speed test flight is a go
who are you talking no no one you were
narrating again i was not just doing the
mission log you do know no one ever
listens to that i know that narrating
helps me focus
ready captain light you ready as i'll
ever be commander hawthorne this is
exciting a new adventure i'm gonna grant
you four minutes to be off planet but
then you come right back to us
to infinity and beyond
and you are clear for hyperlaunch
buzz that was utterly terrifying and i
regret having joined you
buzz lightyear to star command come in
star command
why don't they answer hey
the robots the what
what is happening right now
alicia oh no that's my grandmother but
sucks how long were we gone
62 years seven months and five days
what
i hope you're ready for action because
all we needed was a pilot for what to
destroy the alien ship
i have a plan and i have a team darby
can take any three things and make them
explode
i do this and they shave a little time
off my sentence okay and what about you
well i thought this was going to be like
a fun boot camp workout thing
but it is not
did i get it pretty close i need that
know what i'm saying the harpoons
[Music]
right here
the probability of survival with an
inexperienced crew is 38.2
seems a bit low mission failure imminent
in three grandma always said she
believed in you too
there was a big swelling too i think i
need a bed oh no please record your last
words do not vomit inside the vehicle
you are satisfied with this recording
speak or select one
[Music]
to infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it no
not like that
sorry it's the thing your grandma and i
used to do yeah
would you like to see a magic trick yeah
[Music]
tell me your name
taylor
i was really starting to like you
finney
i almost let you go
[Music]
don't hang up who are you
you know all our names
it doesn't work
hang it up
i made you some breakfast what'd you put
that
salt and pepper
have you seen this boy
my brother he was taken by a man with
black balloons
i had a dream about it
please let the dreams be real
you're getting out of here oh
there's a combination what's the
you're gonna use a weapon
the creepiest damn thing
our country itself is sick
but it's lost its sense of direction
even it's common decency you don't so
much as wiggly fingers
[Applause]
there's a lot of people saying a lot of
things
but in the end you got to listen to
yourself
in that moment
elvis the man was sacrificed
and elvis the god was born
[Applause]
look right in my face
he had no idea what he had done
[Music]
you
hey nothing but
dog
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
elvis presley
if you don't do the business the
business will do you i'm gonna do what i
want to do sing the music that i want
[Music]
they gonna put me in jail
the way you sing is god-given
so there can't be nothing wrong with it
if you don't listen to me
now that your mama i sacrificed for you
would be for nothing
trust me
[Applause]
those people ain't gonna change me now
i think if you dream it he'll do it
i've never met anyone like you
i hope not
[Music]
without me there would be no elvis
presley
whatever once told me
my things are too dangerous to say
[Music]
sing
ladies and gentlemen here's elvis
presley
this ain't no nostalgia show
we're gonna do something
different all right so i'm making like a
little documentary oh it's like a movie
but nobody has any lines and nobody even
knows what it is while they're making it
um
no
tell me about what's life like
it's pretty much common knowledge that
it takes at least 20 shells to have a
community my cousin fell asleep in a
pocket and that's why i don't like the
saying everything comes out of the wash
because sometimes it doesn't or
sometimes it does and they're just like
a completely different person
so it's actually only two of us now
myself and my grandmother anna connie
we like to watch 60 minutes because
leslie stall is fearless
[Music]
sometimes i find my mind wandering
thinking
what would my family think
do you think they could be out there
[Music]
let's forget about being afraid just
take the adventure okay
let's do it
[Music]
hi everybody it's marcel i'm recording
this video because i'm looking for my
family
[Music]
marcel the shell and the search for a
family reunited
marcel how long has it been since you've
seen your family i couldn't tell you but
a space in my heart gets bigger and
louder every day
dean do you know how long that's two
years two years yeah oh that's nice to
know
[Music]
there's so many places that they could
be
marcel the shell with shoes on
you are beautiful
there must be so many others like me
he has got to go
not that i don't like arthur
not that come out no oh my god no no oh
[Music]
good night good night
yes yes yes good night
there are a lot of other villains in the
world
but i am going to be
a super villain
[Music]
i am pretty despicable
all right all right i'm not minnie
please stop calling me that
time to strike
[Music]
my minions will save me
you like picking on little guys huh
i am a master of kung fu
i will teach you
kevin kevin kevin
[Music]
[Music]
you only get one shot
why don't we make this a fair fight
opportunity
[Music]
kids get the popcorn out let me tell you
the story of the space viking thor
odenson
he was no ordinary man
he was a god
after saving planet earth for the 500th
time thor set off on a new journey
well he got in shape
he went from dead bod
to godbod
and after all that
he reclaimed his title
as the one and only
thor
oh spook too soon
jane
[Music]
the old ex-girlfriend
what's the family three four years eight
years seven months and six days give or
take
my uh sensing feelings
[Music]
well you're right
the only ones who gods care about
is themselves
so this is my vow
all gods will die
i just want to say that was very very
impressive what you did back there
she's my first bad guy
you never forget your first
[Music]
you
are not like the other
guys because i have something worth
fighting for
[Music]
let's see who you are i take off your
disguise
and flick
oh you flick too hard damn it
should we help him mean eventually great
[Music]
[Music]
this is harris what would i do without
you this is harris this is the soul of
discretion one would never know she'd
been but for the polish on my knobs
that's what we are by the invisible
women kiss me once you kiss me twice
then kiss me once again isn't it divine
500 pounds 500 quid for a dress when i
put it on nothing else matters my eddie
would love to see me in a dior gown was
been over a long time your head is never
coming
back for the moment dreaming
that's why you're
you're a dreamer
you should have been receiving a war
widow's pension comes quite a tidy sum
who is my attic it's a sign from my
angel what are you going to do i'm going
to buy a dress a christian diode from
paris
paris
i'm
please let me squash you out no no no
hang on a minute i've saved every penny
scrubbing floor so i can buy this drop
excuse me but it would be my honor to
have you view the collection as my guest
[Music]
you are nobody invisible
may i give you a lift
what was i thinking come in here i'm
just a cleaner from london no your
cleaner dreams are the most beautiful
gown in the world
it's not sewing it's fake and moonlight
you dare to follow your dreams mrs
harris
this is not possible not at all where
are you going mrs harris to see the boss
this is house these are for you from mr
lemaki
i've spent too long on my own wishing my
life away you'd want to do the same
thing this is your chance
i have never encountered anyone like you
come on girls follow me today there's a
new woman a modern woman
i thought it was too late now i'm not so
sure
who's that bloke looks the master
himself mr dior he looks like my milkman
in town they tell the story of the marsh
girl
the one who grew up alone in the wild
but they never really knew me
like most stories
the facts don't weigh into it
i didn't know how to do life
i was better off learning from the marsh
hello miss kyle i hear y'all by muscles
the marsh taught me how to survive
but it couldn't teach me everything
you can't live alone the march forever
watch me
all right
it's dangerous to live out here alone
like this
i'm fine you're something else ain't you
miss katherine clark is charged with the
murder
of chase andrews
prosecution has announced it will seek
the death penalty
i'm going to get out of here
one way or the other
[Music]
there were no footprints fingerprints
nothing
someone destroyed evidence
i know you have a world of reasons to
hate these people i never hated them
they hated me
you want me to beg for my life
i won't
[Music]
it's a dangerous world in it i don't
know if there is a dark side to nature
just inventive ways to endure
against all odds
[Music]
why do you want to be a samurai
[Music]
i lived in a bad part of town full of
bad dogs
everybody always picked on me
i thought if i could be a samurai
it would change everything
sounds like you need a mentor perhaps a
once great samurai who has fallen on
hard times maybe could use some help
himself
but where can i find one
[Music]
get out of here who even made that
it's you don't believe everything you
read
[Music]
sorry hank you have to do something
[Music]
you're under arrest
you wanted to be a samurai fun isn't it
go get them
get back out there
[Music]
hey this is the training montage isn't
it sometimes
[Applause]
don't forget to land on your
feet
[Music]
who knew an evil army could go through
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what the mother father cocker spaniels
going on here
the legend of hank
time to finish
this might take a while
did you know that the very first
assembly of photographs to create a
motion picture was a two second clip of
a black man on a horse
and that man is my
great great-great-grandfather great
there's another great grandfather
[Music]
but that's why back at the haywood ranch
as the only black owned horse trainers
in hollywood we like to say since the
moment pitches could move yeah skin it
again
[Music]
[Music]
uh
it's a bad miracle
[Applause]
we got word for that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right tv night with my pro
[Applause]
you're going on a date with lois so
disrespectful
oh hey there little fellah
[Music]
up buddy it is
i have an owner
he's superman and um
[Music]
my dog is the best
but he's not the greatest with other
animals this just seems gross we need
gross smelling stuff is one of the
greatest joys of being a dog next to
licking any part of your body and i lick
myself all the time well that explains
the breath
superman i am lulu and you will kneel
before me
oh aren't you a little ray of sunshine
what's going on
[Music]
you're invulnerable i should be a lot
more dead right now right all of us have
super powers
still working out the kinks i didn't see
anything
are you okay my best friend is in danger
and you have to help me you know what
they say about dogs don't you never feed
us chocolate we love unconditionally
[Music]
we're just a bunch of shelter pets
we're stronger than you think
help you get your dumb on the back
a deployed canine shield what is a k9
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
why couldn't i have gotten a magic
hammer or something
what do i have here
oh squeezy bruce
that better be a licensed toy or i will
freak out
[Music]
i have a story
okay
i'm in west texas where this family just
lost their daughter to an opiate
overdose oh my god i'm so sorry it's
okay it's not something i was close to
but you flew to texas for it
uh
yes uh it was a girl i hooked up with a
few times her family thought that we
were more serious than i did i've heard
so much about you i've i've heard
yeah
[Music]
abilene just didn't die she was murdered
what and the two of us are going to
venture dead
so as like a personal boundary i don't
avenge deaths but here's what i can do
i'm going to record everything that you
think happened to abilene
and we'll put it on a podcast and we'll
see where it leads what evidence does he
have that it was a murder
nothing
and that's the story
what's this podcast about a new american
reality where people invent these
conspiracies you got deep state pill
pushers cartels the law because the
truth is too hard to accept
my prius exploded oh my god what if
you're driving a real car with gas and
stuff
the problem isn't that these people
aren't smart the problem is that they
are how do you take them coffee
in the mouth
if you want people to open up to you you
gotta act like one of us
who here is a diehard fan of the
university of
texas
and who here is a fan of texas town
what if she was murdered
this just keeps getting bigger and
bigger looks like two pairs of prints
cowboy boots calling out an apb to find
two men wearing cowboy boots
[Laughter]
what happened to her why do you care so
much why do you care so little
you're so lucky in you evelyn i really
don't know what you saw
art caesar
texas has a full river
you can't solve something like this with
a 45. it's the breakdown of society's
what it is they're just women i think
that's very wise you're gonna need a 12
gauge couple of ars no western automatic
and a sidearm for safety
where are you right now uh i'm in an
uber
[Music]
hi
there's a gun
this is the quiet car
call he's your small inside voice in his
son there's a gun
[Music]
[Music]
talk to me i am ready you are getting
the new and improved me
because if you put peace out in the
world you get peace back
i think you might be forgetting what you
do for a living
take the gun every job i do somebody
dies i'm not that guy anymore
some conflicts require a gun
[Music]
hey this is nice
okay what am i snatching and or grabbing
a briefcase you said you wanted simple
for your first job back it doesn't get
simpler
you ruin mine
dude i don't even know you
there's nothing simple about this job
something else going on here
yeah i'm not the only one on this train
looking for this case
lemon hmm where's the briefcase oh it
starts [ __ ]
[Music]
it was just there
we are right on settle everything that's
ever happened to you this is gonna sting
[ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] deal
[Music]
[Applause]
oh no thank you you know what do you
have uh anything sparkling
that's the one thank you domo arigato
i'm sure you want to talk this out no
particularly not okay
exclusively in movie theaters
joseph are you coming for easter i don't
know mom i'm really busy i just tested
for this pilot you're going to be a
pilot a network pilot for like a tv show
ah you're playing a pilot on the tv show
no a lawyer you could have been a lawyer
if you only applied yourself
little father and son road trip it's
gonna be fun easter sunday is like the
filipino super bowl there he is there's
mine
welcome home bro see tonight okay i just
got here you got to follow your dream
and become a beer spokesman that was my
dream let's get the party started baby
and i got to follow mom's dream and
become a nurse
joe vanessa yeah joe valencia you still
driving that same raggedy ass car what
what happened you just gave up huh and
it's your dad you know me and him used
to be real intimate back in the day oh
really yeah i could have been your mama
but clearly i'm not yeah i've literally
never seen this many filipinos in the
same place before we're sending gifts to
our family in the philippines i'm
sending this brand new hairdryer if it
makes your hair look like that i
wouldn't send it how dare you how dare
you we should put them both in the box
and ship it my mom is at war with my
tita theresa and they don't even know
why did you really have to wear the same
dress as my mom oh i can't help it if i
wear it better this is war oops
family is a mess we're counting on you
to fix it bye
ladies and gentlemen
we're all we got so let's get the party
started baby
moments like these are few and far
between let's enjoy it
buckle up
filipino families fight a lot make sure
you're not late for dinner but we love a
lot too
your cousin eugene owes me a lot of
money
can you lend it to me no
does he have a death wish deluxe is
legit crazy i once saw him shoot
somebody in a dick what right in the
actual hole in the hole
here we go
where is my money here are my atm cards
my pin number is 12 17. oh oh so it's
mine oh my gosh
yeah why do you all have the same pin
number it's manny pacquiao's birthday oh
right the guy who couldn't beat
mayweather
nasa can we go get coffee you can go
ahead and email me pretty much the same
just take the aol off that [ __ ] nessa
at
daleycity.com got it
abby
if you're watching this it means that
something went wrong
[Music]
i'm sorry
i couldn't tell you
[Music]
i thought that i could make it all okay
i was unlucky in what happened
[Music]
i know him
i know what he's capable of
i think you're
having an episode
i am doing what i have to do
to protect myself
and my daughter from heart
[Music]
it's been 22 years maggie
i just want
you to be happy
[Music]
[Music]
my name is alethea
my story is true
i am a solitary creature by nature
i have no children or siblings nor
parents
i did once have a husband
if there is fate who can say
but in the grand bazaar of istanbul
i chose a memento
i like it whatever it is i'm sure it has
an interesting story
[Music]
so what would you wish for
what is your heart's desire
[Music]
i do have a question
what does one do with three wishes
you'll see
[Music]
[Music]
there's no story about wishing that is
not a cautionary tale
we all have desires even if they remain
hidden from us
but it is your story and
i cannot wait to see where it goes
oh how it might end
hello hello
he'll be staying for a while
i'm beginning to wish we never met
save yourself
i have a wish
[Music]
[Music]
you